I heard we had something in common I
don't know if it's true but not too long
ago I went and visited a Korean spa do
you like a cream with yeah when I went
there with Steven Yeun from Walking Dead
and I had this incredible experience and
then I'm told that you are kind of
obsessed with Korean spa I do love a
Korean spa I am I'm not an exhibitionist
but I do enjoy being naked naked you
like to be naked I do because some
people do I do not I'm very comfortable
I'm one of those creepy people that like
you're at the spa and I'm totally naked
and I see someone I know and like I
don't go grab a job like stand there and
have like a full-on conversation and
people are like trying to avert their
eyes and I'm done that's so nice that
you're you're comfortable with yourself
and I am the way it should be I am I am
comfortable and I do love the Korean spa
experience I love that it's all open so
you know the Korean spa like your shower
doesn't really have a door like the
scrub kind of happens in the open with
other people the scrub I had a scrub and
if anyone's interested you can go online
and look at this because it's on YouTube
uh your scrubs yes my scrub okay don't
worry everything is pixeled out gonna
say you cannot go online and see my
scrub no mine you can see online in
areas are covered as they should be and
but I was beaten beaten by this this guy
really beat the [ __ ] out of me and I was
in pain afterwards and he took like a
layer of my skin off at any point and
it's not good no that's not good okay I
enjoy the scrub and I kind of I get down
with the like a deep massage so like I
enjoyed that but I did have a very
interesting experience once which I felt
slightly violated and slightly happy at
the same time um but the woman it was it
was really interesting the woman that
was scrubbing smacked my ass
I guess that's inappropriate and thank
you definitely I would drive a drift
towards the compliment part of it I
think my case would be thank you sir
Garrett's fascinating but I do I love a
scrub I think it's very important to
remove the dead skin Conan all right
let's get the word out kids I got to
remove the layer
you